welcome everyone it's good to have you
here I see some familiar faces and some
less familiar faces so that's that's
fantastic so what I wanted to do is
prepare to talk and within the talk have
some images a few videos to look at and
there's also a audience participation
component because that's just how I roll
we have to practice what we're up to so
this segment this talk is one that is
looking at pedagogy as not simply
pedagogical strategies in general but to
look more at the ways that I translate
this idea of pedagogy through lenses or
filters of disruption or criticality and
so part of the work that I do
professionally is prepare teachers of
art for k-12 but also work with graduate
students to be as a conductor research
and I also do my own research in
scholarly kinds of moves about the ways
in which visual imagery visual art
visual cultural production functions as
modes or spaces for teaching and
learning Jasper Johns a pop artist
someone who's been relegated into that
space by some critics and historians
this is something that's a statement he
made about his art practice like how do
you make your art what's your approach I
take an object do something to it
and I do something else do it really
well yeah I mean that seems really
simplified but for me that's really
interesting and quite powerful
methodology your method to use you take
something and then that thing is not
just it's not finished it's not done
being whatever it could be and then do
something to it okay I did but then
let's keep it going do something else to
it so for me the doing can happen in a
number of ways you can alter it you can
modify you can throw it you can add
something to it you can take something
away but we can also as viewers
or people who are engaging with that
object we might ask questions so asking
the asking of questions is a form of
doing and so for me
Johnson's quotation is is nice is for me
as a bridge from a more modernist
mindset or approach where it's about the
object and it's about the making in the
process of making to some folks might
talk about the slide into post-modernism
or other post spaces where we move
beyond object Nisour material nests to
other realms that have more conceptual
content and interest that notion of
asking questions are taking object doing
something who are doing something else
to it
you could engage learners like that
right that's one way to engage learners
so if we think about learners we should
also think about curriculum now this is
an image this is not one that I drew but
it's a cartoon for one a single cartoon
panel from non sequitur and I use this
image when I teach curriculum classes so
on the right we have this larger fish
with kind of sharp teeth and there's
stuff falling down from the fish's mouth
and then there are these three smaller
fish and then there's a another fish
that's kind of medium-sized and that one
actually knows how to talk which i think
is an interesting thing so we're able to
fish saying that the medium-sized fish
says no we can't swim any faster the
school curriculum is geared for the
slower swimmers so that ten of you have
to wait for the others to catch up I
don't know about you only see four other
fish I only see four other fish I do see
one fish that the little fish looks like
little fish bits that are falling from
this larger fish's mouth so where is the
curriculum here is the curriculum this
larger fish with the sharp teeth is the
curriculum that the swimming is the
curriculum the water itself this cartoon
allows us to have multiple entry points
to ask where the curriculum resides and
if we think about that word curriculum
it is derived from a Latin word karere
and that's the infinitive to run
so curriculum is to run it's the running
of a course rather than a noun if we
think about it in those terms right some
curriculum theorists did work in the 70s
and 80s to reconceptualize curriculum
but and focus on this idea of curriculum
as a verb to run so the running were in
this case the swimming of the course is
the curriculum so how they swim so
apparently these that I'm assuming the
medium sized fish is the teacher that um
and could be could also be the you know
the school principal or whoever's in
charge there but the the middle three
are probably or supposed to be maybe the
students who seemed to know how to swim
the course the way that it was designed
maybe well this could be one of the
learners to swimming adequately but
sometimes when I have used this with my
students in court in curriculum courses
they talk about how this larger fish
they often call it the Barracuda say
that's the curriculum the curriculum
eats up the swimmers who don't swim in
predetermined ways okay so here at
curriculum is a noun in an adversarial
thing how depressing is that to be a
teacher or a learner to think the
curriculums after you you better stay in
front of it but if we think of the
curriculum as a verb in the ways in
which we swim so maybe some swimmers
swim higher in the water some some lower
some swim sideways some swim faster and
slower how might the curriculum allow
for multiple swimmers rather than a
predetermined and singular notion of
what a learner could be but that's if we
preface or that's if we privilege the
idea of learning right we think about
teaching we could just deliver I mean
there are notions of teaching and
curriculum that from the early 1900's
and late 18-hundreds that would think
that would proclaim that learners are
empty vessels and the teacher has all
the knowledge we just fill you up with
knowledge and that says you're a learner
you don't bring anything to the
classroom but that's not the case you
swim the way you swim bring that to the
classroom
so this idea of shifting from teaching
to learning privileges or allows more
attention to what learners bring to
those spaces
well another standardized approach that
was very popular 100 years ago and still
somehow is its popular within some
circles in art at teaching and education
are the elements of art and the
principles of design some people call
the elements and principles well it's
the elements of art and principles of
design and certainly these are ways to
say look these are the things that are
going on in visual imagery or material
culture but they weren't intended to be
the limitations they were intended to be
ways to gain access to what we're seeing
in front of us
misinterpretation of that quite often
teachers studio teachers are teachers
other folks will think that these are
the limits and if we only talk about
line shape color texture pattern rhythm
then we've covered the curriculum we've
taught what we need to teach that's an
interesting approach if you want to
avoid content if you want if you want to
avoid concepts and ideas and social
issues if you want to avoid lie lie
lived experiences in the lives of other
people and certainly when you're looking
at works of art that are representative
of or reflections of lived experiences
to omit interest in what we're seeing
and what is being represented by simply
limiting it to a formalist and this is
formalist notions then we're missing
part of the conversation so a number of
years ago olivia goudi who is a scholar
at school of the Art Institute in
Chicago she said look we're living and
we're not knitting this modernist notion
and there are different ways that we can
mobilize art practices and she
constructed this set of postmodern
principles by looking at the work that
her students were making during weekend
art classes in the spiral workshop and
she said you know there's other
principles the elements of art
principles of design those seven group
of seven elements in group of seven
principles
we're guiding and have done some some
work in art curriculum but she said as I
look at the work my students are making
based on the assignments that we're up
to in the spiral curriculum and are
focused on themes focused on social
issues focused on concepts focused on
lived experiences she said of all of
these works these seven principles seem
to emerge not that the elements of art
and principles of design aren't there
because I would I kind of dare you to
point to something in the world that you
can't talk about in terms of line or
shape or texture right so she's saying
that from looking at the students work
generated from a thematic approach about
concepts and lived experiences in the
world in text and image is a postmodern
principle hybridity this idea of things
kind of overlapping and molding merging
together gazing the way in which one
looks and the perspective from which one
looks and how one is looked at
representing not just to represent
something but how one's identity gets
represented or how one represents one's
self appropriation borrowing from one
context to another juxtaposition the
critique of two objects or two images in
relationship to each other
recontextualization similar to
appropriation but taking something out
of one context putting in a new context
now it speaks differently about this
other context and layering this this
idea of of how narratives or layers can
be read through each other for multiple
meanings and I love what she says which
is also the pull out quotation from this
article an infinite amount of time is
wasted in misdirected effort because
tradition has a strong hold right I mean
there are other things that we can be
doing but because we're regimented in
tradition we just can't get there all
right so let's engage some learners like
this how about being some learners good
all right I have we have large paper
these are essentially jumbo sized
post-it notes and we have markers we
have markers of different colors most of
them are also gigantic sizes like this
larger cartoon
version of post-it notes and little
markers and what I would like you to do
is we're gonna use this approach where
we're going to do its drive from
think-pair-share
right this is a this approach of
learning where I want you to think on
your own and then you're going to find
someone else to pair with and connect
with and [ __ ] and then you're going to
share your ideas with each other then
we'll share with the group so what I'd
like you to do right now is if you have
something to write with that's great I
don't think we've brought any like
normal-size paper but I'll give you two
minutes to do this first part to think
on your own what I would like you to do
is choose one I'm not going to just
decide for you but I'd like you to
choose on your own one of these tasks
one of these statements and I want you
to come up with a list so if you choose
the first one you're going to come up
with a list of 10 important women in the
history of the world don't show anybody
keep it to yourself for now or you could
choose the second one you can make a
list of 10 important events in the
history of the world or you could make a
list of 10 important human creations in
the history of the world
let's make sense two minutes go for it
and then we'll come back together the
activity that we are doing is one that I
use in a curriculum development class
and also a curriculum theory class
usually near the beginning of this
semester to underscore this idea that
curriculum development curriculum design
curriculum as a general practice is a
political act and it's based in values
it's based on experiences imagine a
textbook company approached you and says
oh you could get this contract for a
textbook a history book we only have
enough money for ten chapters so if you
had 10 weeks to teach a course what 10
topics would you teach you got to decide
what doesn't get taught deciding what is
not in the curriculum is part of the
political acts part of the
decision-making so these three prompts
are ones that I've used for years and
years and years to do exactly what we
did you did it like 15 minutes
I typically spend 15 minutes having the
students generate the ideas then we
spend 45 minutes critiquing and
interpreting we're not going to spend 45
minutes critiquing and interpreting but
I'll lead you through some of the things
that I'd like to do which prompt was
this one this is events this one
creations what was this one creations
women creations now notice the prompts
our will talk about how I worded the
prompts in a little bit I find it
interesting this is just the way I'm
reading with your lists one two three
four of the five lists use numbers my
assumption is that the one entry next to
the number one is the most important
only because it's lists if that's I'm
just kind of culturally you know in that
habit when I see a one I think of that
being first usually first is most
important unless you're David Letterman
you reading your top ten list backwards
if you had a last minute email from the
publisher oh we just got some more money
we could add another chapter to your
textbook but you got to tell us by the
end of the business day today could you
come up with your number eleven right or
oh I'm sorry our budget has been slashed
we have to cut two chapters which two
are the least important these are
questions that curriculum designers
curriculum developers make all the time
teachers how much time do we have in the
semester or the school year to teach oh
we only got so far we got to hurry up
and rush because this is more important
and somebody else told us this was
important so we got to teach well I'm
not teaching that that seems less
important I wanted these are political
decisions but what is in is only there
because it wasn't left out a critical
pedagogy or pedagogy that I like to
enact and encourage my students to use
is one that asks these kinds of
questions is constantly in this frame of
asking even when we have our live
even when we have our decision of what
seems to be important well why is this
on the list and where else does this
allow us to go and if we take Toni
Morrison what can we do with her work
where does her work allow us to go
following Jasper Johns and then where
does that allow us to go right take Toni
Morrison not an object but we can think
it in those ways right take this entry
do something to it do something else to
it
the word most doesn't appear in any of
those prompts did you pick up on that
why do you think I didn't put the word
most in there too much pressure on me I
could have easily written I'm fine with
four-letter words I can just sew too
much pressure for home even though I
think we sort of try to do that is
probably most of my that's the way in
the way of the word important is if you
don't have the most 30 things what
so it's kind of a pedagogical strategy
to take some stress away to allow entry
to remove some of the complications
embedded in just working out the
different values ahead of time anyway I
mean certainly those are important
conversations that not the stress I
don't like them do stress in stables but
to make an activity or allow an activity
to have end points of entry for people
where they feel like they can be part of
that absolutely so it's not fixed
absolutely that notion of curriculum for
a lot of people it's fixed it's done
it's a noun it's not a running it's not
a continuation it's not a springboard
and a prompt you're exactly right it's
like a it's a point of continuous
learning yeah
good stuff all right so let's slide back
up here wow this was 20 years ago and I
was working with hypertext software
story space so you kind of see that map
in the upper left and my idea was I go
to the barbershop and I get my haircut
but I learn a lot of stuff in that
barber shop
I think this barber shop might be a
curriculum might be an educational space
no it's a hypertext there's a bunch of
moving parts and different relationship
maybe it's all of those things so I
started to overlap there's different
thoughts into a piece called Pat's
barber shop one day I asked the
gathering of barbers and clients what
can someone learn in here meaning what
can someone learn in this barber shop
and this barber shop is in Norfolk
Virginia predominantly african-american
segment of Norfolk this was when I was
on faculty at you know many immune
Aversa T so as Pat the owner and lead
barber what can somebody learn here and
according to Pat people learn a lot
about life
education business the street the whole
nine someone else noted with the smirk
they learn what a gram is he was talking
about illicit substances how much you
can get for a stolen TV and that they
can learn that crack is good
we love crackheads what he meant was the
first part he was actually being
sarcastic but the second part was he was
being more supportive in a
matter-of-fact tone one of the barbers
commented if you could put a camera in
here for a week you could make a movie
at one point Pat himself responded to my
question in a melodic chant Oh Jay did
it Oh Jay did it a reference to a scene
in the movie barbershop in the famous
court trial later in a more serious tone
Pat proudly stated younger teenagers
learn from me don't sell drugs be
successful keep a straight head Pat
admitted that in his place you learn
about everyday life and this project
went on for years going in the coming
professor well hey professor guess what
this and they would start to tell me
what they learned recently and so I'd
get new lessons and so this article is
filled with different ways to think
about that barber shop as a hypertext
looking at other a subsequent work not
only my artists and residents here at
MIT this year but I'm also an artist in
residence at a local elementary school
back where I live I've been working with
first graders and third graders so you
know what I did a few weeks ago I talked
to third graders about epidemiology
which is what you do right showed them
this map my intention wasn't to talk
specifically about epidemiology my
intention was to talk about how the
visual representation of ideas or how
the visual representation of data the
visual representation of information
might allow us access to ways of knowing
and understanding that we wouldn't have
without those visual representations so
here we have a segment of London and you
see a bunch of dots there and those dots
essentially are the
the places where Jon Snow in the late
1800s identified people who had died
from cholera and his theory which was
different than the local theory and the
common theory at that point his theory
was people were getting color from the
walk from water everybody else know it's
in the air or it's divine intervention
or something else go in a John you don't
know what you're talking about so I told
the kids this my I didn't tell them this
yet I said here's a map what do you what
do you see how it's a map okay
you know what else you see well I see a
bunch of dots what do you think those
that don't those are the people that's
where they live or maybe that's where
something happened why are there more
dots here none of that I don't know they
say oh wait there's some X's what do you
think those X's are they had all these
ideas well you don't see the X's here
the x's the X is a year oh okay that's
helpful Thanks so what's going on tell
me about the relationship between the
X's in the dots oh well most of the dots
are in the middle and 'muslim around
that green dot in the center I said oh
you know what
that's what Jon Snow thought to guess
what he figured out that's where the
people were getting sick that's what the
people were dying because they were
drinking the water and it was because he
was able to visually represent the data
he could get to this this observation
they thought that was pretty cool then I
told him so now here's a new word
epidemiology but two eight nine year old
saying epidemiology it's great but they
start to understand how visual
representation of information allows
access to ideas in different ways and I
said if you like this map what about
this one other people thought that that
map was interesting too how many
different ways could you represent data
visually using a map other people
thought John snows idea was really cool
they came up oh and then as soon as I
showed this
oh that's Google Maps eight nine year
olds know about Google Maps yeah hmm so
now how does Google Maps play into how
we might teach in elementary school
about space about visual representation
just taking an object and doing
something to it
something else too I do something
similar with my pre-service teachers as
they're preparing to become teachers of
preparing to go out into classrooms to
do their student teaching when they're
trying to figure out how learning and
teaching happens in educational spaces
one of the tasks I give them is all
right go ahead and do your next
observation whatever what you do is when
you sit down I want you to draw a map of
the classroom on a piece of paper and
take with you a marker that you know
will bleed if you leave it too long on
the piece of paper what I want you to do
is I want you to make a note of where
all of the furniture is in the room
entry points exit points which indicate
where the students are when you enter
the room and indicate where the teacher
is by putting your marker down and the
entire time that you're there you move
your marker wherever the teacher moves
when the teacher stops you stop your
marker when the teacher starts moving
you move the market so if the marker if
the teacher stops the marker stops if
the marker stops the marker starts to
bleed it starts to over time take up
more and more space and then I collect
these maps and we look at them we start
talking about the relationship between
where the teacher is in the room where
the learners are in the room how the
content is conveyed we talk about what
were the kids doing over here they're
sitting over here what were the kids
doing when because it looks like the
teacher was over here most of the time
were they talking were they engaged were
they moving around the room I'll show
you some other maps this person didn't
use a marker so they just kind of kept
scribbling and overlapping this is
curious isn't it this teacher is either
exhausted or on rollerblades or
something the teachers all over the
place and maybe not in a bad way it's
really not giving a lecture like I'm
doing right now how do you know well
look at the map well where was the tea
the teacher was essentially everywhere
interacting with different students
moving to one station moving to another
station the teacher filled that space
physically so I'm in the conversations
about that would have to be generated
later would be so then what was
happening among the learners to what
relationship does this teacher movement
have to do with the ways in which
students are learning whoa look at that
teacher
what might we learn about the practice
of teaching in the practice of learning
by visualizing movement you could try to
do with all the students but I don't
know if you have enough fingers to move
all the kids around right interpretation
the construction of meaning or the
attending to the construction of
meanings by talking about it making
sense of works of art ooh you know about
America rock and Schoolhouse Rock when I
was a kid these shows would come on
Saturday morning cartoons between the
television between the cartoon two or
three minute videos Schoolhouse Rock in
America Rock America Rock was a way for
us was a way to learn about the history
of the United States or a history of the
United States so here you see some of
the episodes no more Kings the founding
of America fireworks the Declaration of
Independence the preamble the
Constitution that I know the entire
preamble because I watch School House
Rock We the People in order for a more
perfect union the one at the top is from
no more kings there's King George in the
middle ooh
Boston Tea Party is that big cup still
here in the water no the one on the
bottom this is called elbow room elbow
room elbow room got to got to get me
some elbow room that's where I learned
the word manifest destiny or the term
manifest destiny schoolhouse right this
is the melting pot shaped in the form of
the United Continental United States
little guy just jumps right in it
doesn't matter what your skin those are
the lyrics
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they swore their loyalty until the very
end and you taking your own
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this team they wanted no more mother
[Applause]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
what a great place to live I mean the
president does what the people want
like what else did you learn from that I
just learned that the president does
what the people want
what else did you learn about this
country based up from school has rock
video what else did you learn pilgrims
in the colonists didn't pay any
attention to people living at were there
people living here in this video there
were 300 what we didn't tell me
something Oh things that we didn't learn
that this video wildly misrepresented
and erased a crucial part of history
before and after and he was in the
implications of freedom it was freedom
for white males but it paints a very
nice easy picture of what history was
but is not true and it has repercussions
now because of a pulse well I mean they
only had three minutes I mean you only
had ten slots if you had eleven slots
that no they only had three minutes how
can we put all that stuff in Bing you
know so if you're an art teacher and
let's say you're assigned to or you're
teaching interdisciplinary unit working
with the history teacher you could
justify showing this video I mean
illustration video video production can
be taught through the art classroom the
history teacher can pull the history
there's history being taught I could
justify following a prescribed
curriculum that says history teacher and
art teacher will work collaboratively to
teach together yeah okay we're watching
some Schoolhouse Rock and we're going to
interpret through one of those
pedagogical lenses that well you were
applying many of them in
and we were applying many of them in our
reading of that list so as an art
teacher or just a teacher who likes to
cause trouble or ask questions or
promote critical thinking we could show
these videos like this so you can show
any visual culture example and interpret
and critique through those different
lenses just want to show you a couple of
assignments this assignment is by
another colleague Andres Hernandez who
teaches at school of the Art Institute
in Chicago and so this is a project that
he engaged as two students to do where
he he uses this quotation to talk about
this and to question this term informal
sediment settlements now you think about
refugees you think about people who've
been displaced and to think about the
housing that they have constructed for
themselves as informal really it's as
formal as it's going to get for those
folks in that moment I mean the
terminology itself is problematic and so
he wants he's thinking about this you
know if you think about these kinds of
places it says in fewer words the city
produced by the people so inspired by
the notion of a city produced by people
he he tells the students who were
learning to be art teachers and we have
these open spaces at Vermont College of
Fine Arts you're going to take one of
the spaces and you're going to build a
shelter out of cardboard and it has to
have and there are certain criteria you
have to have certain number of people in
it and by doing that at the bottom you
see the purpose of this assignment is
that it's intuitive building using
limited materials and is focused on a
one-to-one scale or the scale of real
life so right there because it's not a
model because it's scaled at real life
there's a way that our bodies enter into
the reality and maybe into the reality
of other people says further purpose is
to design this design brief is a basic
introduction of site specificity as well
as full-scale prototyping and sketch
modeling and then at the end you know it
can be these models can be used to
design to talk about principles of
structure enclosure construction
techniques all right so these are
elements I would assume that are part of
many other disciplines architecture
urban planning and so forth but the idea
is that he's drawing from a quotation
from a theoretical argument focusing on
a term and saying this term is
problematic let's see what we might
learn and how we might trouble this term
through the act of making works of art
and then those works of art allow us to
gain literally entry points into them
but also entry into the complications of
what those terms mean
here's another assignment Honduras
provides the students find a building
and engage with this spaces and then
document it through photography so what
do you learn about the spaces of what do
you learn about the physicality of a
building by becoming part of that
building but by becoming part of the the
negative spaces you could write about it
you could measure it tape measure or
your body could try to fit in there and
understand what that space is about I
know from teaching drawing one technique
we can do we all had our drawing paper
we could start drawing what we see now
we get us so far but one strategy and
our teacher will always do or often do
and say I want you to draw what's not
there I want you to draw the negative
space and when you draw the negative
spaces between the chair the spaces
between the bars and the spaces between
the handles and the rungs my drawing and
rendering those negative spaces as
accurately as possible
you render the positive spaces so what
do we learn by studying what is not
there or the neglected spaces we learn
more about the presence of the dominant
structure so there are a number of books
about pedagogy and about translating art
practice and and pedagogical engagements
in public spaces right so I'll just
conclude here for some questions I can
you know you can engage learners like
this or you could do boring stuff it's
up to you all right thanks
you
you